- Y'all both look so cute
and you're, complimenting each other.
- Oh, thank you. We match!
- I know, it's like you called each other.
Have y'all met before?
- No.
- Never met before?
- A big fan,
- but a big fan.
- Oh, we met, met like years ago.
- Very long.
- Like long time ago.
- I was a baby.
I was probably like 15, 16.
- I know.
I wasn't that much older.
Like I, yeah, that's what I'm saying.
It was like, it was like, I was older
but maybe like four years, but I was,
- I was 40.
(laughs)
- That can't be possible
- No, it was interesting,
cause I hate acting
but they asked me to do this thing
and I thought it was cool.
It's called American dreams and
I would be playing a singer.
So I was like, well that's
not a stretch, so, okay
- Oh yeah.
- And yeah,
and I got to be Brenda Lee.
- Yes.
- And I thought it was a really cool show
I actually ended up doing it twice.
- Yes, And you were fantastic,
I remember being so star.
- Oh no, you're so nice
But I Just thought it Was
such a really cool way,
because honestly I
learned about Brenda Lee,
I learned about the bands,
I learned about all these bands that
I didn't really know this
information about on that show
I thought it was such a Cool show.
- It was a really ahead of its time show.
I mean, getting people to come on
and play their idols,
or people they wanted to learn about,
it was really good idea.
- No, but I did enjoy it though.
In your whole crew, it was so lovely,
It was a good experience
for someone that's uncomfortable
in that environment.
- Oh no, it was great.
- Y'all were all so kind anyway.
- Thank you.
- So your, new movie where
you get totally slapped
by an old weird person,
we just saw clip from it
that's gonna creep me out for eternity,
It's called X?
- yes
- Is it because it's X-rated?
- it's dealing with,
I don't know how much I can
say on daytime television,
but it's dealing with
an adult film industry,
So it's called X because
of yes X-rated yeah,
sort of, but it's in the 1970s, 1979.
And we're a group of people
making a classy, dirty movie
If that's a thing that can happen.
- I love that's what people
say they're doing, Yeah.
- very right.
- Well that's so we set out
- Toy, dirty movie.
- It's a classy porn.
- Yeah classy porn.
- Yeah. Or an artistic one, I guess,
But then things go awry because
because the old people that you saw do not
like us being there,
it's more layered than that,
I'm doing a bad job of explaining it but
- No, You're doing a great
job with your accent.
- Yeah.
- Oh really?
I was hoping that like
after you heard that
you weren't like, that was not
- No I thought you did a really good job
of that and you shot in New Zealand.
Right? I love New Zealand.
It's so beautiful.
- Have you been there?
- I have not.
I've heard.
It's incredible.
- It's so beautiful
- I have a question.
- I heard they have a fly season.
- A fly season?
- So does Australia.
- In November they have in everything,
insect like poisonous season.
But I heard they have a real like season,
where just like flies.
Is that true?
- Oh, I don't know.
I wasn't there for that, but lots
of really nice people I'm yeah.
- They're so nice.
- Yeah.
- It wasn't like this.
It was more like.
- Yeah. Welcoming.
You were hugging.
Yeah.
Well there wasn't a
huge COVID issue there.
So while you were shooting,
that was probably awesome.
- It was awesome.
We were actually filming
in the middle of COVID.
We went to New Zealand where
there were no cases really.
And so we quarantined for two weeks,
and then I was out in the world at bars
and restaurants and they were
the nicest people ever there.
- So nice.
One time that I had to, well
the whole time I had to drive
on the other side of the road
and I ended up accidentally
being too close to a parked car.
And I took off the side of his
mirror and he was in the car.
And so I pulled over
I'm hysterically crying
by this point because I dunno how to drive
and who would give me a rental car?
They did.
And the guy actually was so nice,
He came out and he was like, oh
I'm gonna try to do an New Zealand accent.
Yeah. I had to fix my mirror anyway.
It's okay.
And I was like, you're
gonna, and he was like
not wanting to take my money or anything.
So he just let me go.
He was like, he needed to
get another one anyway.
- Oh, he was stoned.
(laughing)
- I believe that actually.
- So, and I just Kiwis in
general, the only time you'll ever
a Kiwi Office, if you can
say they're Australian.
- Oh yes.
- It's like the whole
thing of like different
- With that accent i Just did It,
So I'm pretty sure I
didn't ask bar accent.
- I'm pretty sure I just circled no,
it was really good.
So wait, so people would not be happy
if I didn't ask you about Pitch Perfect,
are y'all gonna make another one?
They're so good.
- Yeah.
- I love that You say you can't sing
and you sing like so well by the way
- You sing too.
- Yeah.
- Yes. I've seen you.
Yes
- I sing, but I don't sing like,
I mean, like I can sing to my dog,
you know? Well,
- Can we sing a notch?
- She sings on like, yes, girl.
Let's do it.
Okay.
- What thing she said?
No, what's the thing.
- What's the line
- A line.
- Yeah, We just need,
I don't the one line between the three.
We sing it together.
What's the line.
- Oh, like a verse,
- like a verse yeah.
- That's Okay. Are we going hymn?
Are we going like amazing grace?
What are we doing here?
Okay.
- Oh my God this is a nightmare.
- Oh my God I'm taking a Kelly Clark
- Wait somebody start cause I'm a soprano.
So I wanna start low enough.
I don't know where your ranges are.
- I don't have a pitch.
So, you know, See you.
♪amazing grace ♪
(inaudible)
- It was bad.
- No, it wasn't.
- You just said you had
a problem with pitch.
I gotta honest with you.
I was like she is bold or
she has a problem with pitch.
She's like, let's sing.
And I was like this was not gonna go on.
- I have the worst pitch ever.
- No, you have great pitch,
I was right on pitch.
- I hope she's listening.
(laughing)
- I love that,
That's never happened impromptu.
I love how much she's sweating right now.
She was like, she said what?
No, but the movies are so good,
you're such a great singer in them,
you love doing them it's a fun cast.
- Thank you.
(clapping)
- I do love doing them.
I mean, I get to be with my best friends
and we get to sing and dance.
- That's cool.
- And you get paid to do that.
So it's kind of a no brainer.
No.
And so I would love to do another one
because we would just get
to all be together, but
- We'll do one, we wanna watch it.
- Yeah.
You can make a call better than I can.
- I'm making a call right now.
Make it happen.
- Can you be in it?
- I wanna watch.
I'll do that.
You can sing, I can sing.
As long as I'm not acting, you
want your movie to do well.
You know what?
I think we now, I think we now know
that this movie should end
with us singing three
harmony and amazing grace.
(laughing)